good morning to you it's seven o'clock
you're watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster now a boost for
the vaccine rollout with
moderna jab starting in wales today but
will it help
counter the current slowdown in
vaccinations
and one of the new questions around the
astrazeneca vaccine
well that's the minister for small
business who's on the program
shortly plus we're launching a new
climate show today
much more on that in just a moment
this morning my spider sense is tingling
at half past nine we'll speak to the
photographer
using action figures to create marvelous
movie scenes
we'll get some of his secrets of his
craft
and milk before water really new
research reignites the debate over how
to make that
perfect cup of tea we'll talk to a
qualified tea champion
at a quarter to 10. it is wednesday the
7th of april
climate crisis how a quarter of people
in britain
wouldn't change their habits to fight
climate change
what wouldn't you give up
vaccine booster modern the jab rollout
to start in wales but
new questions over the astrazeneca
vaccine after trials in children are
paused
calls for an inquiry we try to track
down the unite union boss after a
hundred
million pounds of members money was
spent on building a hotel and conference
center
we report from the prison holding the
kremlin critic alexi navalny amid
reports of his health
deteriorating and snatching the crown
what happened when a contestant in a sri
lankan beauty pageant
didn't like the result
and it's becoming less cold and less
windy over the following few days but
there will still be some rain across
northern areas
i'll have the full details for you later
in the program
a very good morning to you lots of
questions to answer in terms of our
vaccine rollout this morning the
government minister will be joining us
in just a moment but first almost a
quarter of people in britain are
unwilling to change
key habits that would help tackle
climate change that's according to an
exclusive poll conducted for sky news it
comes on the day sky news is launching
the first
daily prime time news show dedicated to
climate change
here's our climate correspondent lisa
holland
the changing landscape reflects efforts
to halt the climate emergency
drive around britain and you can see it
for yourself but what about
our individual habits at the services i
met a trio of environmentalists heading
to wales in their hybrid car
to go walrus spotting they don't need
any convincing the planet is in peril
people's attitudes is like they can't be
bothered an exclusive yougov poll for
sky news showed nearly a quarter of
people
are not prepared to change a single key
climate habit
this includes things like never driving
a petrol or diesel car again
or paying more to fly abroad
for now none of us are actually allowed
to holiday overseas but heading into
wales to the fontegari leisure park
gareth and merwin evans admit
convenience
not climate concerns guide their travel
plans
we're concerned about climate change but
its
impact on us is negligible
the yougov poll found more than
two-thirds of people
don't feel personally impacted by
climate change
we might not realize that climate change
affects us all
or be prepared to make the changes
needed
but the poll shows a growing realisation
of some of the issues driving the
climate emergency
the high percentage of people understand
the definition of climate issues
such as carbon footprint and renewable
energy
but much lower recognition of terms like
the cop climate conference
and its president and climate minister
alok sharma
do you know who this is no
alex sharma
david is worried the government could
end sales of bikes like his
that bike is it diesel petrol but it
goes like
well i wouldn't want electric bike be
too slow when they only last
five away with two young children who
are
going to be around and obviously see the
effects
climate change it have probably more
than we will in my lifetime
friends of the earth say the messaging
on climate policies needs to change
i think the emphasis does need to be on
on the benefits that
are to be gained from um from tackling
climate change
um they're endless really when when you
start to think about it
in this pivotal year for the climate not
everyone is yet on board
on the uk's journey to net zero lisa
holland sky news barry
later today sky news is launching the
first daily prime time news show devoted
exclusively to the climate crisis
and it's hosted by anna jones here on
the daily climate show we're going to be
covering the changes happening to our
planet
and meeting the people who are coming up
with the solutions and it's not just
about recycling and planting trees
though
this is our data dashboard and it helps
us track in real time
what's happening to the world right now
you can see for example the temperature
going up as i speak and also how much of
our power right now is being generated
by
fossil fuels and by renewable sources so
you'll be able to watch us at 6
30 and 9 30 a free weekday evening here
on sky news
and you can listen to our weekly climate
cast podcast
and watch our digital show from friday
as well
and the daily climate show launches
tonight here on sky news as anna said
you can watch it every weekday at half
six
and half nine now our other main
story this morning the uk's fight
against kovid 19 is getting a boost
with a new jab the modern vaccine being
rolled out
in wales now it joins pfizer and the
oxford astrazeneca vaccines to become
the third to be approved in the uk
so far the uk has ordered 17 million
doses of the moderna jab
it is a two dose vaccine so that's
enough to vaccinate eight and a half
million people
the vaccine's minister told us that
modena could be rolled out in england
around the third week of april first
batch arrived in scotland on monday
it's not been confirmed when the rollout
is going to start in northern ireland
now the new jab comes as ministers and
scientists work to dispel
fears over the astrazeneca vaccine after
a trial on children was paused by the
medicines regulator investigates a
possible link
to rare blood clots analogy i've given
is crossing a road
you look right you look left you look
right again there's no traffic
it's safe to cross the road you can
still trip you can still
stumble these things happen but but is
it was it safe to cross the road
yes it was but nothing in life is risk
free
well the minister for small business
consumer labor markets paul scully joins
us now
good to see you this morning look how
concerned should we be
over the astrozedica vaccine
particularly when it comes to
we think people under 30.
i think the mhra are doing their um that
their work
the the astrozenica vaccine is uh is
safe
it's saved thousands of lives it's gone
out to
millions of people both here in the uk
and across the world and it's continuing
to save lives so my message would
clearly be if you get invited to have
your
vaccine please do because that's the way
out of the pandemic that's the way to
get
uh just continue saving lives our
community but also
restoring our economy and getting back
to a semblance of normal life
as you say it has saved many many lives
there's no doubt about that but it's
it's not about the people necessarily
who've received it at this stage is it
it's about
these concerns seem to be about the
younger generation i mean
you support i presume the fact that the
trials in children
i think their age six to 18 have been
stopped at this stage
well it's right that the scientists do
their work that they make sure that the
vaccine is as safe as possible that
they're
they look at any possibility there's no
uh proof as yet that there's any um
causal links uh from the very very rare
uh
occasions that there have been um talks
about blood plots
um and so it's right that they do their
work but but at the moment that you know
everything is showing that the vaccine
is safe but it's um
it's best to get it as you've heard from
the scientists before and this is why in
today we're also really releasing the 20
million power fund to extend
our life sciences because we've done an
amazing job in rolling out the vaccine
in good order
with 300 million pounds going but we
bring 20 million more into
allowing our life sciences industry in
this country
to flourish look i mean if it's
necessary to pause a trial
and and and obviously we need to
particularly with children we need to
act very cautiously are we reaching a
point where the regulator should be
pausing astrazeneca full stop until we
know more
especially as we now have moderna coming
on stream
no you've got three vaccines coming on
stream and it's excellent the modern
vaccine is being rolled out in wales and
it will be rolled out across the uk
uh later on but but the um the mhra
and other scientists will be doing their
work looking to make sure
they will only uh vaccinate people
when they know that it is safe that's
what the regulator is there to do and
it's it's it's
determined that it's safe for adults
they will continue their work on on
children in the in the weeks to come
well forgive me that's not the case is
it i mean obviously they
they they aren't convinced it is
completely safe i mean every
drug that we take even if it's just
taking a paracetamol there are
there are certain risks linked to it i
mean clearly there are concerns
because of what's happened in other
countries and and now the the stopping
of this
trial i mean that no one can turn around
and say this is a hundred percent safe
that's not what i'm saying no i mean
there were clearly what i'm saying is
that there's no causal things between um
blood clots and um astrozenica that have
been uh proven
as yet so that's why it's right that the
the scientists do their work
but uh but clearly the the um as you've
heard from
just a short time ago um that it is the
best thing to do
in order to to keep all of us well all
of us
safe is to have a vaccination when it
when it's determined to do so
the regulators would not regulate a drug
that is proven to be
unsafe where are we in terms of getting
moderna
rolled out in england i mean obviously
it's uh
it's been launched in wales today which
is very good news of course to get
something else on stream but
but when are we going to see it here in
england you'll hear in the next few days
it's the uk vaccination program the uk
has spent 300 million pounds on rolling
this program out
three out of five uh people within the
uk have had their first
vaccination so far so it's going
incredibly uh you know at
pace as as expected and you'll see
coming to the
to england and the other developed
nations um across the next
next few days the next the next few days
well by the by the end of the week
perhaps
well you've had you've heard the
vaccination minister the vaccine
minister and even
we're talking about the third week of
april we're already just about to start
the second week of april so that's not
too long to wait i think to get that
third vaccine up and running and then we
can continue our
excellent progress on the vaccination
program well
are we still in terms of the vaccination
program are we still on target to hit
all adults by the end of july because
what are we looking at now 2.7 million
jabs
a week which is yet slightly lower than
expected yeah we always knew that uh you
know the beginning of
going into april that the um uh with the
supply
issues that we've had that we just need
to make sure that the supply was never
going to be consistent right the way
through the program
but we've also been concentrating on
second jobs as well
to make sure because people are coming
up to their 12-week period
since they had their first job so it's
important that we keep that program
going as well
but as far as i can see everything is
pointing to being
remaining on target can i ask you about
the whole passport issue because
obviously that's causing
quite a lot of concern i think
particularly on your own back benches
not to say that the labor party
not happy with things at the moment what
is your understanding as to
who is going to be potentially affected
by
a domestic covid passport is it likely
to apply to
some of the small businesses which you
represent as minister
well uh the prime minister has been
really clear that when uh william hasn't
been
to be fair he hasn't been this is
supposed to when we open the
non-essential retail
and hospitality next next week um there
will be no requirement for certification
there will be no
requirement for certification uh come
may the 17th when we get to stage three
as well
what is being looked at is um the
entire gamut around the ethics and the
practicalities of a certification
program
and especially for um sort of ticketed
events bigger events and
that's why it's linked to the events
research program which is doing its work
through this month and
is due to report back uh next month so
there's plenty of discussion plenty of
debate to
to look at before we uh before any
decisions are taken
i mean what is your understanding about
the
the future then for small businesses uh
are you saying that that's that level of
non-essential retail you you're not
expecting them to ever have to deal with
this passport issue
well i'm saying the the the the work
that's been done at the moment is
concentrating on
ticketed big events and those kind of
things because there are they are
tougher to get back to a semblance of
normal
rather than the high streets with
non-essential retail and
and uh and hospitality including pubs so
so that's where the work is being done
at the moment but as i say there's a lot
more work to be done a lot more
discussion and debate
to be had on that over the coming weeks
i mean how
how much are we are we being led by
other countries the united states
is uh obviously you know that's ruled
out federal passports i mean individual
states could do their own thing
on that and yet on the on the other hand
we're seeing a lot of the digital
passport work being done in countries
like israel i mean how much are we
looking at what is happening in other
countries
we're looking at other countries
definitely i mean i was just i've been
speaking to some of the hospitality
sector yesterday you talk about israel
they don't certify for going indoors and
clearly the weather is very different
than uh
uh in israel when you look at
hospitality settings so
it's all of those kind of factors that
we need to consider um
as well as as i say the ethics the
practicalities and those kind of things
around it which will be discussed over
the over the next few weeks
i mean earlier on you mentioned this 20
million pounds which is going to be made
available
for for people in life sciences in that
industry
to bid for extra funding what
differences is that actually going to
make in securing us
against future pandemics i mean on the
surface and particularly within the sort
of monopoly money we've been talking
about
over the last 12 months 20 million
doesn't sound like a lot
it builds on it's it's it's wider than
just simply pandemics
we have a well-beating lion life
sciences cluster in my
own constituency in southern gym i've
got the institute of cancer research
with the voyal mars and using some of
the cancer drugs that they produce there
they use um a system called mr liner
which is an mri scanner plus an
x-ray scanner put together that's made
in crawley but
this this 70 percent of our life
sciences
um sector is actually outside london and
the south
east so what it does it helps out build
our health resiliency it helps build our
economy that building back better in the
industries of the future
across the regions across the uk as well
look minister uh we're out of time but
good to talk to you this morning thank
you
thank you uh let's talk to our political
correspondent joe pike i mean
the minister they're sticking to the
line about astrazeneca that it is
safe to use that despite the fact that
these concerns are being raised
yeah and the government are in a very
difficult position stephen
it didn't necessarily make complete
sense that he said
everything has shown the vaccine is safe
and you said is that can you guarantee
100 safe
that's not what i'm saying he replied
but saying there's no
proof of calls or links to blood clots
the problem really is
this is about balances of risks and we
know that
for most people especially if you're
older the risk of getting covered is far
bigger
than the potential risk of blood clots
it's different
in different sort of calculation
different balance of risks when you're
talking
about younger people but the fact there
are restrictions in countries like
germany
and canada is significant the fact that
this oxford child
trial is being paused is also
significant but let's also look at the
most recent numbers from the mhra they
saying they're saying that up to the
21st of march there have been
18 cases of these blood clots after
30 million doses so it does seem pretty
insignificant
risk but certainly something that they
clearly need to look at
on modena rolling out in england
scotland northern ireland in the next
few days the minister said
and finally on vaccine passport another
issue the government are in a difficult
position over not really wanting to
clarify
he said the pm has been clear you're
pointing out that he really hasn't
at all but focusing on ticketed events
like sports events and perhaps theater
events too
that is significant because we know
labour who are skeptical of this
are likely to support a vaccine passport
for those bigger ticketed events
okay joe thank you well still to come on
the program
this morning cutting out the pills at a
quarter to eight i'm going to be talking
to a senior nurse to talk about new
guidelines from the medicines watchdog
advising against the use of painkillers
for some people
who have chronic pain hikers
have been evacuated from a volcano in
iceland after
it began erupting again at twenty to
nine i'll talk to
a geophysicist in reykjavik about how
concerned they now
are and at 10 to 9
i'll be talking to chris packham who's
calling on us all to think more about
the welfare of
the chickens that we need
now the police officer who trained derek
chauvin who's standing trial for the
murder of george floyd has told the
court
kneeling on a suspect's neck while
handcuffed was
contrary to his training lieutenant
johnny mercel
a use of force instructor said mr
chauvin's actions went against what he'd
been taught he's a
latest officer from minneapolis police
to give evidence at the trial
and was asked about the use of force on
mr floyd's neck
sir is this an mpd trained
neck restraint no sir
has it ever been
[Music]
is this a mpd authorized restraint
technique
uh knee on the neck would be something
that does happen in use of force that
isn't unauthorized
and so if there was uh say for example
the subject was under control and
handcuffed
would this be authorized i would say no
we can see continuous coverage on sky
news streaming live on our website and
app
and on youtube and also a special pop-up
channel which is on sky
524
one in three people who contract
coronavirus will go on to develop a
psychiatric
or neurological condition within six
months of being infected
researchers at the university of oxford
analyze the medical records of more than
236
000 patients mostly from the united
states in the largest study of its kind
the study reveals anxiety is the most
common condition
amongst covet sufferers i think it tells
us that we need
services across the whole of health care
from mental health
through to neurology and spiritual
medicine and so on because the
consequence of kovic can be so diverse
the different people will present with
different combinations of difficulties
so really across the board
we need to try and make sure that
services are organized and resourced in
a way
that will allow people to get effective
treatment as quickly as possible and in
the end that's in all our interests
if we can all get people back and
healthy and functioning again
brazil's coveted crisis has been likened
to a biological fukushima after more
than 4
000 deaths were recorded in a single day
a brazilian doctor compared the virus to
a nuclear reactor setting off a chain
reaction
and going out of control the country's
total number of covey deaths now stands
at 337 000 second only
to the united states
friends of the imprisoned russian
dissident alexis navalny says health is
deteriorating quickly
mr navalny is on a hunger strike
demanding better medical attention
the authorities insist he's being well
treated
well our russia correspondent diana
magnay reports from the prison where
he's being held
east of moscow
stay back he's saying inside those
prison walls is alexei navalny
on hunger strike for almost a week
because he says
he's not getting the medical care he
needs for serious back and leg pain
now with a fever and bad cough too and
according to one russian newspaper he's
been moved to the prison hospital
do you think that it is the kremlin
behind the fact that he's not getting
the medical attention he needs
absolutely yeah
putin news
[Music]
press filming police filming press
anastasia silva who's head of the
alliance of doctors tweeted
that she was on her way met not by a mob
of police
but my mob of journalists
she's a close associate of alexey
navalny just out of house arrest herself
for calling for rallies during the
pandemic
what did they say to you the policeman
they said that
i have no possibility now to visit the
chief of this
prison i don't know why but
i should not visit a medical worker
because they
don't allow i don't know why i think
that we will wait
waiting though turned out not to be the
best call
she and six others were detained
including a couple of journalists
last week these cctv pictures of navalny
pacing his cell were leaked to state
media
the narrative there that his medical
complaints don't add up
maria bhutan an expert for russia's
commission maria bhutaner who was jailed
in the u.s
in 2018 for being a foreign agent was
the star attraction
on state broadcaster rt her contention
predictably that navalny was fine and
that jail in the u.s
was worse the kremlin says any prisoner
who's ill will get the appropriate
treatment
but navalny isn't any old prisoner
lofty dreams invested in one man behind
bars for the foreseeable
his health in question his supporters
helpless to do much about it
dinah magnay sky news pakrov russia
now how about this for a bit of drama at
a beauty pageant
there is a rule that you all have to be
married
and not divorced so
well the winner in the miss sri lanka
contest had the crown
snatched from her head on stage over
claims she was
divorced pushpika de silva walked off
the stage in colombo in tears but
reports now say she's been
reinstated as the winner
[Music]
oh dear dude i don't know
i don't quite have to follow that to be
honest if
naz had a crown on let me tell you i
would not dare rip it from her head
whether i've been divorced or not um
well lots of sunshine for this morning
sunny spells this afternoon as well but
it's still staying cold although
feeling less cold as the winds will be
lighter
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it's looking fine over the
next few days
still cold though but not as cold as
recent days because the winds
will be a lighter and the winds actually
briefly changing direction
into thursday so it will be a bit of a
milder story too but
only briefly the rest of the week looks
generally cold so chilly start out there
this morning temperatures are below
freezing in some central areas or
widespread frost there's also the risk
of ice and we have got wintry showers
across northern scotland and western and
eastern coast in fact it's
rather windy around eastern coastal
areas with gales there but the winds
should tend to ease
the wintry showers becoming confined to
northern parts of scotland this
afternoon and we continue with largely
fine conditions
through today with bright or sunny
spells although there will be a gradual
buildup of clouds so
there won't be waterfall sunshine like
there is across many areas this morning
and as i said there will still be some
wintry showers across northern scotland
perhaps a few around some coastal areas
winds becoming light around the east
coast though
and with the lighter winds it won't feel
as cold but temperatures still
in single figures for many areas later
then we'll also see
rain spreading to parts of the north of
island northern ireland perhaps the far
south west of scotland spreading
eastwards through the night
now the government has again this
morning emphasised the safety of the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine after a trial
on children was paused
while the regulator investigates a
possible link to rare blood clots
the minister for small business paul
scully said that people should continue
to come forward
to get the jab they were clearly what
i'm saying is that there's no causal
links between
blood clots and um astrogenica that have
been uh proven as yet so that's why it's
right that the
the scientists do their work but uh but
clearly
the the um as you've heard from calm
semple just a short time ago
um that it is the best thing to do in
order to
to keep all of us well all of us safe is
to have a vaccination when it when it's
determined to do so the regulators would
not regulate a drug that is going to be
unsafe
let's have a look at the latest figures
for you and 2 379 you covered cases have
been reported
with 20 more deaths across the uk now
that takes a total number of people
who've died to
hundred 126 eighty-two in terms of the
vaccine 31.62 million
first doses have now been given
well let's talk to professor of clinical
microbiology at the cambridge institute
for
therapeutic immunology and infectious
diseases
ravi gupta good to see you this morning
look in terms of
astrazeneca and the fact that this trial
on
children age 16 to 18 has now been
halted
how concerned should we be
well i think that it was absolutely the
right decision to to
halt the study in uh uh in children
pending further investigation of um
the the perceived uh increased risk of
from um blood clots uh in in adults so
i think that it's not anything to worry
about um but it's
but it's important to to to have the the
information in front of us
before we proceed with studies in
individuals who are less likely to
benefit from
from vaccination directly i mean this is
the problem
isn't it that it causes concern
understandably so
but the risk here from what we know so
far would seem to be in the younger end
of the population
and not those people who are most at
risk from developing
very severe covid symptoms
that's right so so the increased risk of
blood clots was
also seen in adults below 55 but you
know we also need to remember that
people who are uh who are you know
in their 20s 30s 40s 50s are also at
risk of severe covid19 we've seen that
with the new variants that
there are anecdotal suggestions that um
that younger people
are developing severe and
life-threatening disease so uh
there is an argument for the vaccination
to continue in those
individuals because the rate of this um
blood disorder is extremely low although
slightly elevated above
background levels so there's a case to
be made for for older adults but for
children
of course the the reason for vaccinating
them is to actually
cut down transmission in the community
in the main and therefore
i think that halting studies in children
is not going to have a serious impact
um population level but it's it's just
good practice to do this
so are you saying you would have no
concerns from
for any adult i mean at 18 or over i
guess and
actually taking this vaccine when
they're eventually called forward
i think that uh the uh on on balance at
the moment there's still transmission of
of sarskoff ii um and there
is a risk to all of us are being
infected uh particularly as um the
economy is being opened up and society
is opening up we are we are at risk of
getting severe infection all of us so i
would certainly be going forward for
that vaccine
uh in the current situation if uh uh
because i'm in that age group so yes i
think i think it should be continued
how much sort of easing on the system
does the modern vaccine add now i mean
it's gonna cover
eight and a half million people it's
it's 17 million doses
that we've ordered i mean how much
better is it to have
multiple vaccines like this on stream in
the uk
it is always good to have a range of
different vaccines because as we are
seeing
there may be unforeseen um
peculiarities of certain vaccines that
aren't evidence in the um
in the initial trials that are done so
post trial surveillance
that we're doing now looking at rare
side effects
is is something that happens for all
medicines and
um and therefore having a range of
different medicines is important
and because each one will have certain
issues with it there is no perfect
vaccine there is no perfect drug and
and i think the government did uh made a
very good decision early on
to spread the risk
across different vaccines and also to
spread the benefits across different
vaccines
and so i think the the madonna vaccine
sorry the uh the
the the madonna vaccine will be um
really welcome as an addition
professor gupta good to talk to you
thank you
thank you now uh joe pike is back with
us this morning because you've been
looking um into this what's a very
strange situation with the unite
union and some huge amounts of money
they've been spending
yes indeed in birmingham big uh hotel
conference center and union office
project
and unite the union are very significant
because they are labor's
biggest donor you might not think trade
unions are as significant as they were
in the 70s or 80s less industrial action
of course but there are still many
millions of people some suggest
six million people who are members of
trade unions
that makes those organizations pretty
wealthy and the people who run them
stephen
pretty influential he is a power broker
a king maker lem mcclaskey helped ed
miliband become labour leader
and jeremy corbyn hold on to the job but
after 10 years running unite the union
his power seems to be waning his chosen
candidate rebecca long bailey
failed in her bid to lead labour
mccluskey himself is due to stand down
in the next 12 months
and now he faces accusations of cronyism
over the union's development of a new
hotel
conference center and union base in
birmingham
and its construction contract awarded to
a company owned
by a friend the now almost completed
building may be in birmingham
but the foundations of this story are on
merseyside
len mccluskey was born here he worked on
the docks and joined the union
but it's also where he made links that
would last a lifetime
the man on the left is paul flanagan he
runs liverpool-based building company
flanagans mccluskey described the firm
as a working class family who've made
good
and never forgotten their roots
flanagans was given the big contract
to build the hotel overseeing health and
safety on the project
a different company owned by david
anderson
the son of former liverpool mayor joe
anderson
all three men have been arrested on
suspicion of bribery as part of a
corruption investigation
not linked to unite they all deny
wrongdoing
and have been released under
investigation there is no suggestion of
any criminal wrongdoing
in the union's dealings with either
company
but there are now growing calls within
labour for an investigation
into unite the obvious answer to a lack
of transparency is to have an
independent
inquiry and i think that's absolutely
the right thing to do i think that's
what the members would expect
i feel angry i feel this is an
outrageous abuse
of positions to use members hard
earned subs to fund a project that's
gone catastrophically wrong and there's
been no apologies
the development was originally supposed
to cost around seven million pounds
before work began in 2017 the union
estimated the bill would be 57 million
but by january this year the total cost
was just over 98
million pounds the big question for
unite and its members was this building
worth it
it was supposed to save the union money
on hotel bills and conference costs
but now it seems like the million spent
here could take years even decades
to make back the lack of transparency
huge overspend concerns about tendering
and the fact lem mccluskey is unites
only paid elected official
meant we wanted to speak to him
the union ignored our request so we went
to their london headquarters
to try and find
in the him before eventually getting
through
by phone we just wanted to speak to you
if it's possible about
your birmingham hotel and he told us to
call the press office
and they said mr mccluskey did not want
to do an interview
when we asked unite they told us their
initial estimate for the project was too
low
but the costs increased over time money
was also spent adding an extra floor to
the building and turning it from a three
to a four-star hotel
they reject a lack of openness in the
tendering process saying len mccluskey
wasn't involved
but they will not name other companies
who applied for the contract
this building will be len mccluskey's
legacy
the race to succeed him officially
begins within weeks
joe pike sky news birmingham
well let's talk to the shadow defense
secretary john healey who joins us and
lots to talk to you about this morning
but can we start off with this
unite situation are you comfortable with
what's going on
really isn't for me or any other labour
mp
this is a an independent trade union
it's accountable to its members that's
where the
principal answers need to be uh
sought and of course there's a legal
system of
investigation and certification through
something called the certification
officer so there are
ways forgive me forgive me but how is
how is this not
the concern of any labour mp because
many labour mps are members
of unite unite is the biggest
donor to the labour party and indeed
unite funds some camp parliamentary
campaigns for some
mps when they're standing in an election
surely this is the concern of the labour
party
no this is probably a matter for unite
to answer and the general secretary to
answer
to the members and any other challenge
through the certification officer
my concern and i work very closely with
unite my concern is for the united
members
in the defence and aerospace industry
around this country that have seen 30
000
defense jobs go over the last decade
through a combination of government cuts
and a
failed policy of global competition
which means we've seen
contracts placed overseas instead of
building up the british
manufacturing and technological base in
this country and that's
that's that that's that's the sort of
action and uh
um involvement i want to see um
and that's where i want to see unite
most active are you a member of unite mr
healey
no i'm not but you talk about the
members who you
uh are dealing with the defense sector
are you not concerned about the 100
million pounds of their money
that's been spent on a project that was
either meant to cost 7 million ended up
being best part of a hundred million
pounds
and there seems to have been a total
lack of transparency into how
this uh bid was tendered out no i'm a
i'm
i'm not a united member i work very
closely with united and other trade
unions i'm a labour party
shadow cabinet member where the party of
working people and trade unions
my concern my principal concern is for
the 8 billion
of government investment in defence
that's been stripped out over the last
decade
my concern today is to make sure that
ministers don't make the same mistakes
over the next decade
and we need instead a proper built-in
britain
plan not a competition by default plan
we need an annual report to parliament
so that we can see the proportion of
taxpayers money
from britain that is going into british
jobs and british companies
and we need to see a national plan to
support the development of some
first-rate
small and medium-sized companies so that
when we come to commission what we need
for our national security and our
military
uh in 10 years time we're in a position
to build it in britain instead of by
having to buy off the ship from overseas
yeah forgive me i mean the labour party
is
is very keen and perhaps rightly so to
to point out
you know claims of cronyism against the
tory party when
where these are things that you know are
alleged
it is a labor party not tainted by your
biggest donor
by miles facing accusations of cronyism
my point to you is quite simply these
are properly questions for unite and the
unite leadership to answer
to their members and publicly and to any
challenge through the certification
officer there is a framework in place
for dealing with these things
my concern is shadow defense secretary
is different minds mine's an industrial
not a political interest
and that's where i i do most of my work
with the unite union
which is would you support an inquiry as
bradshaw mentioned
that's not a matter of for me and um you
know other labour mps have their own
views
my concern is for the government's
defence policy
investment in our manufacturing base in
this country and as far as unite goes
for those many thousands of united
members
that are producing some of the vital
defense and security equipment that we
need to keep us all safe
but in term in terms of that defense
equipment i know you
you're pushing for this you know a
commitment to
to to get british to build british
in terms of all that level of
procurement what if that doesn't prove
to be the best value for money
well there's always a question of value
for money um
but we've got to we it's but
we believe that when it's done well and
it's not been done well enough over the
decade that investment in britain's
defense industry in this country
reinforces our economy and covid tells
us
the risk of relying on long
international supply chains means that
when it's done well it can also
reinforce our security and our
sovereignty
that should be the priority for the
period ahead
but in terms of of how you know things
are tended out and how we work in
in a market economy if there is a
guarantee of buying british
that removes some of that that that
market competition doesn't it
i'm proposing today a higher bar for any
contracts that
are put overseas and there will always
be cases where it makes sense to develop
new strategic systems with allies or in
some cases to buy from overseas
we need a higher bar and a presumption
that we will look to buy british first
we've not had that over the last 10
years we need it now
not just for our economy and our jobs
right across the uk
but for our greater nationals
independence in future
and our security as well what commitment
can you give as the shadow defense
secretary to the men and women
serving in our armed forces should you
come to power
i can give the commitment that as we've
done as a labour government in the past
and you'll hear kirsten and i both say
this we both served in government
the first duty of any government is the
defense of the country
the support of our armed forces and the
safety of our citizens and we take that
responsibility just as seriously in
opposition
john healey good to talk to you thank
you thank you
did you know that if we all work
together we can really make a difference
to the air pollution around our schools
yeah
we should really do that
most places will be fine and dry this
afternoon with some sunny spells but
it'll gradually become cloudier through
the day
wintry showers over the northwest will
ease but later outbreaks of rain will
spread across northern ireland the
northwest of the republic
and perhaps far western fringes of
scotland it'll be a cold day everywhere
again
but not as cold as previous days so
taking a look at the air pollution
levels on a scale of 1 to 10 with 10
being very high
most places will remain at a low level
of one to three again
however some isolated moderate levels of
four to six may persist
in the shetland and orkney isles as well
as the far north coast of scotland
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
now if you suffer from chronic pain if
you know
just how awful it actually is and people
who have that chronic pain with no
known cause should not be prescribed
painkillers that's according to the
medicines watchdog at least which has
today set out new guidelines
recommending
they should instead be offered a range
of therapies including
exercise acupuncture and antidepressants
now the national institute for health
and care excellence says that pain which
lasts for more than three months
is known as chronic or persistent pain
it's sometimes caused by an underlying
condition
like osteoarthritis rheumatoid arthritis
or endometriosis
and that's known as a chronic secondary
pain
now where the cause of the pain is
unclear it's called chronic
primary pain and that's what this new
guidance focuses on
for a long time uh the expectation that
there was a pill for every ill
was one that lots of us had and we
thought that when we had pain
the medicines that we thought of as
painkillers could adequately control
that
what we know from new evidence and
what's absolutely backed up in these new
guidelines is that that's not the case
and that actually these medicines when
taken for a long period of time
actually don't work particularly well
and cause a significant number of side
effects themselves
it's very important that the public
understands that the
the risk benefit has shifted and now
actually the risk of taking these
medicines on the side effects is higher
and the benefit of taking them is less
than we previously anticipated
well let's talk to hazel taylor senior
nurse and clinical director
at washington primary care network good
to see you this morning
look i'm just trying to put myself in
the position of someone at home watching
right now who suffers from chronic pain
with no known cause
who are going to turn around and say i
don't i don't want acupuncture i don't
i don't want to be prescribed exercise i
want a pill that's going to make life a
bit more bearable
yes i mean you can understand patients
have been on these medicines for a long
time and they're going to be anxious
and i think it's our jobs as um doctors
and nurses and people in primary care to
to explain all the um alternative good
treatments that are now for people
a lot better than they have been in the
past and i think we've relied
totally on painkillers is the fix for
all these ales and
and now we need to help people
understand that there's so many other
things without the side effects
that come along with painkiller
management
the painkillers will only last for a
certain length of time then they stop
work and then people find themselves
taking
stronger and stronger medication and so
i think it's our job to try and
use the education of other medicines of
other
therapeutics physiotherapy exercises and
you know cognitive behavioral therapy
things that can really
help people's mind and and help them
focus on
improving the pain without the side
effects and long-term and ill effects of
painkillers
but how how comparable are the effects
of
of of some of these a cognitive
behavioral therapy or
or acupuncture how does that compare to
the effects of taking
something like a an opioid a tramadol or
or um
a a cocodemol or something like that
i think this is how we have to shift our
mindset i think because we're so
used to using those um and quite often
there there is a place and i was in
early
acute pain and then people often then
end up taking these pinkers for much
much longer than they should be on them
and i think that's where the problem
lies that nobody has then
re-educates him right now it's time to
reduce those tablets
and look at some of the alternative
therapies and they are very beneficial
there's been lots of studies to show
that if you can slowly educate people to
change down from medication
and we wouldn't suddenly stop medication
that's not the aim of this it's not
suddenly to say right we're going to
take that away from you and give you
this
it's a it's a communication with the
patients and these are some of the
therapies that are out there these are
things that we can try should we try and
reduce your medication slowly and and
there's different um therapies for
different patients like everything
patients are individual
so you would have to decide well you
know this might suit you
in negotiation with the patients so it's
getting them on board i think
um to understand the other therapies
that we can use what if it doesn't work
um what we've always got um we would
never say no you can't have anything
that's not
the the game and if people are in acute
pain
and need to increase painkillers then i
think that's always there there's no
no there's a there's a place for
everything but there's a lot of people
on these who don't need to be on them so
um there is still people that might need
to be on painkillers that's what they're
there for
um but there's also a lot of people on
them that can easily like change and use
alternatives that have never been
actually offered to these alternatives
so they don't even know
they exist and there's lots of side
effects with painkiller management
that people if they start reducing off
them suddenly feel better they feel
better in themselves
they're not tired they're not fatigued
these can increase weight all sorts of
problems with taking long-term analogies
it's
that people don't often understand or no
and so i think we need to give people
the opportunity
is there a perhaps a misunderstanding in
a way that we think if we have a chronic
pain
that there is going to be something out
there that can remove that pain
altogether do we have to have an
acceptance that we're going to have to
put up with some level of pain or
discomfort
yes i think so i think there is um the
myth that you know we're going to be
completely pain-free and even
analgesics are not completely pain-free
because often we find with patients
we then start to increase the analgesia
because that level isn't working
and then they'll go back again and we
increase them again and i think this is
about it and understand with the patient
that some level of pain
as long as you can live with it and
maybe do exercises
and mindfulness and things that help
with that pain
and you can still get by and live there
today and live quite well
but you might not get rid of every bit
of pain that you've got especially
things like arthritis
um you know where you're going to have
discomfort and some days are not
going to be better than others but if
you're on strong analgesics all the time
for these things so it's trying to
manage the the pain better and have a
better understanding over the
long term consequences of it look hazel
taylor really good to talk to you this
morning thank you
very much okay let's go to check on the
weather for you with nas
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning the following few days will
feel less cold because it's going to be
less windy and in fact we see a change
in wind direction briefly on thursday
with a milder air flow but then we go
back to
more cold air flow into the weekend so
let's take a look at this morning it's a
chilly start it's sunny though for many
areas it's mainly dry as well except
across northern areas of scotland there
are wintery showers there around western
and eastern coast as well in fact around
north sea facing coast
very strong winds that will tend to ease
later we'll see brighter sunny spells
this afternoon a buildup of cloud though
through this afternoon then rain later
over
the north of ireland northern ireland
and southwest scotland